I'm sauce pour manager discuss
competition award some research will be
presenting in advance in number theory
well I'm Charles Pugh and I will give
you an overview of advance obviously
feature advance in number theory so
essentially in this talk what I plan to
do just to give you an overview of what
we are doing and kind of show you a
concrete case so we are trying to kind
of revamp our number theory right and
our push essentially is first we want to
improve usability so that means
documentation and I will show you what
you already did
so if you get there in our page is easy
to learn you understand the function are
such but also obviously we want to
improve the algorithm we want to you
know extend the scope we want to have
the state-of-the-art the fastest the
best so that's also in plan and
obviously we want to you know the
performance so the fastest so what we
try to do just to kind of give you an
idea so and a couple of example how we
plan to do that and you know hopefully
in the next couple of release will
update most of the function hopefully so
first in terms of usability and in this
case I'll probably talk about prime PI
what we you know we first think we buy
to the ability in two part why this
first the ease of use and there is also
the land ability so first for the land
ability is model documentation is well
you know when your user you have access
to the function so in this case what we
did is unfortunately I'd haven't yet did
format it on the new is not yet in the
bill but arbitrary to enhance that so
what we've tried to do is first to
improve the you know the basic data if
you have the earlier version you can
actually open it and see the difference
so in this case we kind of try to you
know to tell you give you the definition
most natural one you know Caesar you
know known has also so something which
is similar you know define you the scope
of the function try to
give you an idea deform so this one well
the best thing you can this coffee
speaking given asymptotic expansion
something visual so something have to
look nice in that page so in this case
we kind of show you that is kind of
controlled by those and as usual we have
the metered option so in this case you
know we introduced method option this is
if I'm not a big fan of meat reduction
so to mission is fine and like in this
case what we know the best algorithm
usually you just run it but for this
type of function you know some people
like to use you know all diagram or
compare so what we did here we are
supposed to standard algorithm from
dilemma to the Legrand Miller and such
algorithm so you can actually specify
them and then hum them and also probably
also explain more about the progress
reporting which is part of the ease of
use of the the function so that's kind
of the detail that we are proving so we
change it for I believe 70 or more
number to a function so that I've been a
whole project we have been going to
improve all of them and after that you
have the basic example so we try to be
sample and idea in this visualization
and in this case we show you that as
them to TQ can actually get asymptotic a
special I will probably not I was
planning to talk about asymptotic
especially the relation between oh and I
think Nam battery for this talk but I
will keep it for next time
Devendra will come next time probably we
talked about it on so nice example
I can't compute asymptotic on you know
no battery functions and well after that
you have the scope so we broke the scope
into numerical evaluation obviously
there's always a numerical evaluation
for function so we show you the scope of
an integer of a rational number search
and we have symbolic manipulation so
which function can handle it so kind of
to show the scope and such so you take
you to 52 integrator your fitty to find
sequence for some can we recognize it as
such so we kind of try to show you the
scope and that kind of show you the
integration of
that function inside the language well
next what we try to do so I will jump
the rest we try to put a lot of examples
to kind of you know we try to give you
that intuition builder when you open the
documentation page you kind of get an
idea of what Pam PI so a lot of
visualization a lot of examples you know
from basic table to spiral of time pie
or so so you have nice visualization to
just learn what's the function and get
an intuition and after that we have in
this case approximation right if you get
more into hard code part you know how
you can approximate it from a man and
such and the last part is about number
theory
so the strange ring it open from the
bottom switchback well the number to me
like in this case we show you al you can
use it to complete room time as such and
essentially is kind of give you an idea
how you can construct it so that's kind
of pretty much that job what the learn
ability so our plan essentially is you
know Trempealeau documentation and it's
going to be in 12.1 and we hope that in
the future version will extend it to
other related number to a function as
well as probably YT course so people get
more introduced to that and the next
part is actually the ease of use you
know one typical thing is when you have
unfortunate like that and we make it
fast on sauce you want to be able to
control it interrupt it control the
memory allocation and all this stuff so
we kind of improve it and in this case
as I was showing their prime PI we
introduced a progress reporting
tentatively function so you can get
actually progress bar to get an idea of
the progress of the algorithm
we have to do the magic so no so what is
depend on the function right so usually
it's often estimate right so there is
Tooting like in this progress reporting
right you first have to be able to stop
it
right specially like in the case of pine
pie but it was multi-threaded you need
to be able to exit correctly without any
issue right and fast enough and for the
time it's option estimate it's kind of
what we rely on so we know what we are
syntactically the the time we are going
come on we only a couple of example and
then we find the whole formula to give
you an estimate says model that
perception has a user that something is
happening right currently if you type
I'm PI of well if you do prime power 13
as I will show you like to tell you that
is too large but in principle if you
want something you're just roughly
speaking huh some people say oh it wrong
I'm waiting ot happen right so this is
just to make you that feeling that
something is happening it doesn't have
to be exact
wait um well let's actually show you a
case right so well I will show you a
kiss first
well I will jump to the next part which
is the scope and I will show the example
so in terms of scope what we find try to
improve is the ability of prime PI to go
above 10 to the 13 no 10 to the 14 in
this case so as you know if you evaluate
this investor on 12 it will tell you
well it's a too large for this
implementation so in the current version
you evaluate it you will get that value
right and you can go higher essentially
so let's see so in this case if you do
progress reporting progress reporting
goes to 2
so you get a nice bar on Denver in this
case is fast enough that you don't see
it but let's suppose 16 so you have a so
hopefully we will try to estimate and
you know do something it does not to be
really exact so that's kind of roughly
the idea but we hope that we probably
should be able to give some rough
estimate for each algorithm depending of
the deliverer and in the case of prime
PI essentially since we use the LMO you
know actually that you know you are
competing for this number of live or
such you have a feed estimate of that so
in terms of scope like prime PI while we
improve it so hopefully now is the state
of the art so and currently you can get
to ten to the twenty seven or twenty ten
to the 30 right so there is no more that
limit after that you just well wait I
don't know how long to get that but
you'll get that progress report I should
be able to actually stop it and the
algorithm is multi-threaded it have all
the nice fancy feature fast enough okay
so here actually I kind of give an idea
of the performance there's pretty much
nothing to argue about the plot there
so you see roughly speaking at the
beginning we're plus or minus there are
pretty close but as you go to larger
number well twelve twenty much hang or
go to infinity so that's pretty much it
so that's a great improvement we were
kind of happy aboard and here is just
kind of the comparison between those two
Matic method as well as if you use a
custom metal at you know John method so
you see the difference okay and
obviously if you implement from PI you
will get PI because Hoffa speaking you
need you know you need prime PI to
compute time so it's awfully
computational prime PI and then sieving
so also there we kind of cause that
limit so prime time also have that limit
on on
which was - to the was twice twice that
number ten to the thirteen right so now
you can actually go higher and get it
efficiently hopefully what it's
computing but you can actually cause
that limit I'm surprised that's taking
that much you will get back at some
point so we have those improvement for
all the power you know time function
time pipe I'm and
as well as well I bought it white as
well as you know random pine right so
essentially what we discover is if you
implement essentially pine pie fast
enough you pretty much get improvement
for all those function so random pear
essentially you want to you know sample
time following certain distribution so
hopefully something uniform so this is
kind of the standard algorithm if you
want to get it uniformly just compute
prime pi plus or minus one here compute
prime pipe selected numbers and then use
prime to come back so there you get
exactly the uniform distribution right
and when the number get extremely large
well then there you just use the star
this trivial algorithm while you
essentially sample and in order integer
and check if it's pine thank you so and
that one is close to uniform statistical
distance from uniform
so having prime pi you also have a
performance improvement on random pile
and actually up to the ten to the
thirteen I think that's the boundaries
we change now you actually get exactly
uniform so with sample actually exactly
so which is actually good so we can
actually determine that okay so well
I want to kind of hopefully give an idea
of whether that we are essentially going
on you know we hope actuator and pull
those those functions so one is
essentially look at you know what's the
state of the art what people actually
build right so when we have it one of
the TV notice essentially is that we can
take advantage of you know having a
fixed-width integer type because usually
number torii all the Algrim play on
dispatching based on the size of the
number most of the time I should correct
that Marcus or your face but yes so and
based on that essentially you know you
can focus on a specific implementation
and dispatch to that implementation so
is what happened with pine pine now and
we think that you know not we think we
started to do the same for factor
integer so like in the case of factor
integer for the quadratic sieve like you
know hopefully limit to quadratic sieve
currently is the best up to the hundred
decimals right so that means you have a
fixed size integer type you can focus on
and if you make your implementation fast
enough will to try that you get all the
benefit so that's kind of our plan
essentially we find the best algorithm
we work on a fixed type we make it
multi-threaded I will make sure to
disperse on to know the right bound and
lately with when we actually hold three
hold prime Q roughly based on that same
principle using the strong Luke attest I
mean both strand with Kukoc test and you
can actually also get that performance
you know Alice you know 50% improvement
in you know in Ronnie time so that's
kind of the general plan we are going
around with we're just pushing the
directions so I will not really push and
bore you with all the technicality
behind so if anyone have question about
how we make managed to trick it or do
some multi-threading well feel free to
catch me later so that's pretty much a
general overview I wanted to give about
number theory
thank you
[Applause]